là tu vas bien s'allonger qu'est la même
chose
c'est une rentrée hors norme chaque
année ces futurs ingénieurs d'affaires
démarre toujours leur cursus en kaki et
au milieu des militaires du 1er régiment
d'artillerie de bourogne un vrai choc
des cultures
on avait tous des petits préjugés un
petit peu et puis on a pu voilà ont
confirmé certains en eux d'autres se
dire que c'était pas du tout ça et et
voilà au delà des ordi ça reste vrai des
personnes comme nous toujours je vois
désagréable mais voilà quoi ceux qui
sont équipés vous garder ici et on vous
fera passer au compte goutte d'or est
tranquille donc oui c'est super gentil
veut sauf des fois qu'on peut être au
garde à vous tous à risque en plus
strictes mais là ça va ils sont c'est
bien encadré se trouve ça et alice tente
fait pas semblant la préparation
militaire dure une semaine et tout le
monde y passe
effectivement c'est obligatoire pour
tous les élèves de première année
maintenant si vraiment quelqu'un ne
souhaite pas le faire on les coudes bien
entendu on n'est pas là non plus pour
pour les faire souffrir uniquement mais
on s'est aperçu qu'on fait avec le recul
il leur restait toujours quelque chose
de très positif à la fin de cette
semaine
et si l'armée à m'accueillir ses
étudiants c'est aussi parce qu'elle a
besoin d'eux
[Musique]
l'idée pour les stores bien sûr c'est
créer un esprit de cohésion très raté
d'un que la mayonnaise prenne rapidement
au sein de la promotion et nous l'idée
l'arrière français qu'on a c'est
évidemment de recruter des officiers de
réserve d'or avec un bon potentiel
le stage militaire se terminait ce soir
mais le repos sera bref pour les élèves
dès lundi ils retrouvent leurs écoles et
leurs salles de cours